[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEBO ADERIBIGBE: My
name is Debo Aderibigbe.
I'm a product manager
here, at Google Cloud.
And I'm joined by my
colleague, Stephen Elliott--
also a product manager
here, at Google Cloud.
And we focus on creating
value for you guys--
the customers and partners--
by focusing specifically on
the billing product area.
Now, I know we're going to
go over a lot in our session
today.
And don't fret if
you miss anything,
there's going to be a
recording available on YouTube,
after the conference is over.
But more specifically,
today we want
to focus on helping
you make your dollar
go further with GCP.
Now in order to do
that, we're going
to go over four
main areas today.
The first is an introduction--
the what, the why,
the how of using GCP.
We're then going to move
into how you can drive value
using GCP products.
Then we'll focus on what
cost management tools you
can use in order to ensure
that you're driving that value,
but also, saving your costs.
And then, finally, we'll
wrap up and review.
So without further ado, let's
go into our introduction.
Now, there's the
obvious question
we have to answer first--
why are businesses
moving to Google Cloud?
It's a great question.
When most companies are
transitioning to Cloud,
the first thing they're
often looking to do
is to reduce their costs.
But that's not all.
From developers and DevOps
to C level and board level
initiatives,
companies are looking
to take advantage of
not just reducing costs,
but increasing efficiency,
and increasing reliability,
and making sure they
have great security.
Essentially, Google
helps you better
engage with your customers.
It also helps you better
engage with your partners.
And it helps you to increase the
productivity of your employees
by making sure both
your needs are met.
And you have room for
further innovation.
Now, I'm sure you've
heard the phrase,
a picture is worth
a thousand words.
So indulge me for a
moment in a mental picture
by means of an analogy.
Pizza-- who doesn't love pizza?
Now I'm going to go
off script a little bit
and say pizza is, like,
one of the best meals ever.
So bonus tip-- you can
have pizza for any meal.
But just going
back to the point--
there are two different ways
you can think about pizza
for the means of this analogy.
The first is on-premises pizza--
that's the pizza that you make.
And then there is
Google Cloud pizza--
that's the pizza that we make.
As you can see, there's a number
of different tasks associated
with making on-premises pizza.
And each of those tasks,
including spending the time
to go get the
ingredients, spending
the gas, spending the
money, and, of course,
the thing you can
never get back, time--
are actually pretty high
when it comes to making
them on-prem pizza yourself.
But when you go with
Google Cloud pizza,
it's really simple
and fairly elegant.
You go online.
You order the pizza.
You wait.
And you enjoy that
tasty goodness.
When you're going to make
the analogy between pizza
and being on-premises,
it's really
similar to how you deal
with your IT infrastructure.
What you focus on
is dealing with all
the varieties on-premises of
tasks that you need to do.
And we focus, on our side, of
extracting all the management
that you have to do with those
tasks and doing it for you.
So really when it
comes down to it,
we're making sure that you
get the most value out of it.
On top of that,
we help you answer
questions that are fairly
difficult to answer
on your own on-premises.
Like, what if I want
a specialty pizza--
all the meats, all the veggies?
What if I want to make
hundreds of pizzas
and deliver them
to my customers?
We help you scale.
So that brings us to the main
context of our talk today,
which is thinking about
the base equation of where
I get my net value from.
The big idea that most
companies typically think about
is that lift and shift
means extracting the value
from moving to cloud,
by just thinking
about reducing my total costs.
And then, seeing that
as a total net value.
Now, that's true-- reducing your
total cost is a great thing.
But the fact of the matter
is, it's not an adequate way
to think about the big picture.
The truth about cloud is
that lifting and shifting
your workloads is not
really the entire picture,
and does not transform
your IT by itself.
Instead, you should really
think about bridging the gaps
in between your current business
processes and the modernization
and the innovation you can
achieve by moving to cloud.
The more and more you use GCPs
technologies, the more and more
you're able to accelerate
the amount of value you
capture from moving to cloud.
So I like to think about
this is an iceberg picture.
In this instance, there's
the obvious costs,
which are using your compute,
using your other resources
on the cloud.
But then there's the
less obvious costs,
like, all that takes to
maintain that infrastructure
on-premises.
And then there's the value that
you get from abstracting away
your concerns about
all the cloud work
you do on-premises to the cloud.
And then there's the less
obvious value you get
such as efficiencies,
productivity, reliability,
security.
So let's alter this
equation just a little bit,
to make sure that we get the
full value of moving to cloud.
Really, the change
in net value that you
can enjoy when you move to
cloud is really the total value
of being in the cloud itself--
all the things I just mentioned.
And then you subtract from
that, the total costs.
Now for all of you
guys are saying,
Debo, it's way too early for me
to be doing math this morning--
let's simplify it.
Just think about
your total value.
And just think about
your total costs.
This has worked
fantastically for our friends
over at Vendasta.
They focus on doing just
that-- getting their value out
of a lot of GCP products.
And then analyzing that value
using BigQuery and a number
of cost management tools.
They've been able to grow
their business by 32%,
while keeping their
costs relatively flat.
I imagine a lot of you
could do the same thing
by using Google Cloud.
So let's stop talking about
this in an abstract way,
and let's talk about it a
little bit more concrete way.
Let's focus on GCE, or
Google Compute Engine,
as one of the first
products we can show you
how to drive more value.
The typical costs
of compute ownership
are spread across a
number of elements.
One of them is the building.
You've got to pay the rent.
You've got to cover the
electricity, the lighting,
the AC, and the security.
You've got to think about the
software, operating systems,
management utilities,
software licenses.
You've also got to
think about people--
all the specialists, the
consultants, your employees,
and HR.
Oh, yeah, there's one
more thing we forgot--
the hardware.
You've got to make sure that
your compute is taken care
of on-premises so
you can actually run
the workloads you care about.
So there's not just that you
have to think about, as well.
You also got to think about
how you actually drive
the value of your business.
Let's start with
the hardware costs.
Every 18 months or so, your
hardware, more or less,
becomes out-of-date.
And to keep that up-to-date
has a cost associated with it,
if you want to make sure
that you remain competitive
with those in your industry.
You also want to take advantage
of all kinds of innovations
that are fairly expensive to
come up with your own on-prem,
such as, GPUs TPUs, artificial
intelligence, and machine
learning.
You also want to think
about how you might serve
a new region of the world--
let's say-- if you want
to globally expand.
Or let's say, that your
business is doing fantastic,
and you want to make sure
you can scale very quickly,
especially if it's not expected.
And so that's where we
enter Google Compute Engine.
The simplicity and elegance
of it is its core value.
You start the virtual
machines that you
need for your workloads
when you need them.
You resize them and
scale, as necessary.
And then you shut
down that VM when
you're not using it anymore.
The key to that is you pay
only for what you need.
Well, you guys didn't come
for the base explanation
of what a virtual machine
is or how to use it.
So you really came
for finding out
how you can drive even
more value out of using
GCE and other products.
And that's very simple.
I like to spread it into two
elements-- behaviors and tools.
On the behavior
side, you definitely
want to analyze and
plan your workloads.
Think about seasonality.
Think about the duration.
Think about the value
of your workloads--
are they mission critical?
Figure out how you want
to segment those, and use
the right machines for them.
The second thing
I tell you to do
is think about virtual
machine types or families.
Now, we offer a number
of different ones.
Of course, there's
general purpose VMs,
but there's also different
optimized VM families that you
should take advantage of.
For example,
compute-optimized VMs,
if you want to think
about performance.
Or memory-optimized
VMs, if your storage
is very important to you.
Or platform-optimized
VMs, if you're
thinking about specific types of
operating systems or platforms
that you want your virtual
machines to run on.
Then, of course,
the third behavior
you really want to focus on is
resize the VMs as necessary.
Think about VMs being built
of core and RAM and sometimes,
additional attributes--
like attach persistent disk
or other things like that.
Make sure that you're using the
right size for what you need.
When we move over to the
tools part of what you're
going to do with
your VMs, you want
to make sure to take advantage
of the Stackdriver API.
Now, the Stackdriver
API is fantastic
because it's really giving
you logging, monitoring,
and alerting right at your
fingertips, programmatically.
On top of that, we
give you what we
like to call right-sizing
recommendations.
Right-sizing
recommendations allow
you to have the
proper size of VM
after we've watched you
use those VMs for a given
period of time, in order
for you to save money or be
efficient in the
way you use them.
And finally, there's a
number of other tools
that we'd like for you to use,
such as VPCs or sole tenancy--
which means just having your
workloads alone on a VM.
Access control,
snapshotting of disk images
to make sure that
you can get quickly
running with your VM, and
other types of tools like that.
Now I told you in that equation
earlier that I mentioned,
it's not just about value.
It's about decreasing
cost, as well.
So let's take a look at a few
of the ways you can do that.
We have custom machine types.
One of the things that's
interesting about all
those pre-determined machine
types that I just mentioned
in the previous
slide is that they
tend to follow a specific
ratio of core to RAM.
If you need to, you
can break that ratio
and have a custom
machine type that's
flexible and well-priced.
If you want to have a workload
that can withstand some
interruption-- let's say,
once every 24 hours--
you might want to think
about using preemptable VMs.
Preemptable VMs
might get preempted--
as their name suggests--
and they're cheaper.
You can also use
sustained use discounts.
Now, this is a great thing
that you get automatically
for long-running workloads.
When you're workload's
going to run
on a specific type of family--
the longer and longer you
use it, the more effective
discounting you get.
And finally, there's
committed use discounts.
When you commit to using
a certain amount of core
and RAM per month on a
one or three year basis,
we're able to effectively scale
and plan capacity for you.
That planning equals
savings on our part,
and we're more than happy to
share the discount with you.
Now, I've talked a little bit
more specifically about GCE,
but there's a number
of different benefits
you can enjoy across
all GCP products.
And that includes,
but is not limited
to the fact, that we have
planetary scale and networking.
These are not just the services
we're using to help you.
But they're also the
same types of services
we use to run many of
our most famous products,
like, YouTube,
Gmail, and G Suite.
We also have site
reliability and support.
Think about them as very,
very intelligent babysitters
for your workloads.
Making sure that your
precious workloads
don't do anything weird
while you need them to run.
We're backed by Google
Security, which, of course,
I don't need to tell
you how important it
is to be secure when you're
running your workloads.
And we've got GCP-wide
tooling, logging,
and APIs to connect you to all
the resources that you need.
So let's move forward
in the compute spectrum,
where my partner,
Stephen, is going
to talk to you a little
bit about all the value
you can extract from products
in the compute spectrum,
in terms of different
ways to manage them.
STEPHEN ELLIOTT: All
right, thanks, Debo.
So I'll spend a little time
talking about managed compute.
And this is where we move
from being able to provision
virtual machines to actually
managing the infrastructure
and operations for you
so you don't have to.
So just to get a sense of
where we are in the room,
can I get a show of hands--
if you feel comfortable,
of course.
You don't have to--
but if you think
your teams and your
software application team
spend at least 25% of the time
maintaining the operations
of the infrastructure.
Anyone thinks that's true?
At least 25%?
How about, at least 50%?
So just in the
theme of this talk--
which is to think about
both cost and value--
just think about what would
happen if you could reduce
the amount of time
the team spends
on managing infrastructure,
managing operations,
maintaining the applications,
doing version management.
If you could reduce that by
half, or 3/4, or in some cases,
just fully reduce it and really
just focus on writing the code.
And there's a couple of sessions
in this talk where we'll
be talk about managed services.
And that's really the
game we're trying to play,
which is help you focus on the
application you're building.
So Debo talked about
Compute Engine--
and that's on the left
side of the screen-- which
is something that gives you
full control over the servers
that you're provisioning.
And then at the other
end of the spectrum
is Cloud Functions, where
you just write the code,
and that function runs in
the cloud automatically
provisioned, automatically
scaling with events
that trigger them.
And then in between,
we still give you
a choice for how much you
want Google to manage for you.
So let's talk a little
bit about those.
What really is the choice?
And I think, it's
a choice of what
you feel comfortable managing.
So in some cases,
people love scheduling.
And people love looking at logs.
And doing the monitoring
and having full control.
But they're either applications
that don't need that level
of control or the team
just doesn't-- that's not
their expertise.
That's not what they want to do.
So the more and more
we can manage for you,
the more we believe you
can focus on doing what's
really important in the cloud.
So how do we do this?
So there's one word that really
captures how we do this--
it's plastics.
We just do it with plastics
or-- sorry-- containers.
Containers are--
the way to think
about this is in the legacy
world in bare metal servers,
you're managing everything.
You're managing the hardware,
the racks, the operating
systems--
you're updating those.
The library's
making sure they're
consistent across deployments.
But what if we could manage
the hardware for you?
Great.
So now you are able
to rent servers.
We can virtualize that to
make that more efficient
and rent servers
through something, like,
Compute Engine.
But what if we could manage
that even further and say,
well, don't worry about
the operating system.
Don't worry about other security
updates or library updates.
Just deliver that
hermetically-sealed piece
of code that contains all
the library dependencies,
all the code that
you want to run--
that's a container.
And they don't interfere
with each other.
And so what you
deploy is what runs.
And then if we can manage
that even further and say,
don't even think
about the library.
Just write the Python,
write the code,
write the JavaScript
that you want to run.
And if it's a common
version or flavor of it,
it'll run perfectly.
We have a lot of
experience doing this.
So Google was one of the
pioneers in container computing
and Linux.
And we've been doing
this for over 10 years.
And one of the
important things--
I'm not going to read
all the benefits of being
able to compute this way--
but as you can abstract a
lot of the dependencies out
of your application, you
get all these benefits.
Whether it's portability, speed,
the velocity of your team,
security.
The dev team knowing that what
gets shipped to production
is going to run the
way they tested it.
And just, simple scalability.
So one thing we like
to talk about at Google
is sublinear scaling.
So I don't know if
you've heard this term,
but it's the idea that
as your business grows
and as your application
grows, your team
doesn't need to scale in
proportion with the success
of your business.
Certainly, you wouldn't
want it the other way
around, which is every
new user requires
even more resources to support.
So to give you a sense
of how this works--
over the last 10 years, using
containers behind the scenes,
we launch about 4
billion of them a week.
Our ops fleet has grown 10
times faster than the ops team.
And that's really great order
of magnitude sublinear scaling
that we can achieve
with this technology.
So where does this appear
in managed compute?
Well, the first
one I mentioned--
on the left hand
of the spectrum--
is Google Kubernetes Engine.
So what this really is--
if you're familiar with
Kubernetes--
it's a way to manage a
container cluster on VMs.
And you could either run
this-- it's open source.
It's one of the most
popular GitHub repositories
that has a lot of
activity and mindshare
from the developer ecosystem.
You can either run
it yourself or you
can use GKE to let
GKE run it for you,
manage the cluster
for you, update it--
do all the security updates.
And then because open
source and portable--
you can still interact with
the cluster master through
kubecontrol-- or kubectl,
some people call it--
directly.
So the management can
be invisible to you
because you're still interacting
with the cluster the way
you're used to.
If you'd like more management
of your applications
and you really
don't want to deal
with deploying applications
into a cluster,
you might choose something
like Google App Engine.
So I mentioned, this is in
the middle of the spectrum.
Here, you can focus on writing
code in common languages
that might represent the
big App Engine Front End App
icon or the big App
Engine Back End app icon
here, and call other services
as needed to do the job.
But you're really just
focusing on the versions
of those applications.
And letting App Engine scale
that application for you.
And then finally-- this
is really exciting--
is just Cloud Functions, where
you can literally go in--
there's some other
great sessions
where you see how short the code
is-- but just go into the UI.
Enter the code.
It could be several lines
that responds to an event.
This event could be a new blob
is put in your GCS bucket--
I want to do something that.
I'll send it somewhere, maybe
do a little bit of processing,
zip it up.
That could be a very simple,
short, and sweet Cloud
Function, where you don't need
to worry about where that Cloud
Function runs.
How to provision it.
How to set up the networking
and the environment.
Just give us the function,
and we'll run it for you,
and automatically scale it.
And only charge you for
the resources it used.
And so that's the
important part-- which
is as you move
through the spectrum,
we're very keen on making sure
you pay only for what you use.
And, of course,
what you use varies
based on how managed you want
that infrastructure to be.
So in the Kubernetes world,
you're paying for the cluster--
those are the VMs that
the cluster is running on.
And the App Engine world
is paying for the instances
that App Engine is
spinning up for you
that's running the back end
and front end applications.
And then Cloud Functions--
it's really just the management
fee, the invocations
of the function,
and the actual compute cycles
run by the Cloud Function.
So on this slide,
what I want to capture
is just what I've
talked about, which
is these different
levels of management
that you can choose from.
And so if you are choosing
Kubernetes engine,
you're still saying you really
value the control over some
of the cluster management, over
the application deployment,
over setting that up.
But if you don't
value that controller,
that's just not
worth it to you--
you can go through the
spectrum and get to something,
like, Cloud Functions.
Where you're just focused
on writing the code,
and pay only for what you use.
And there's no right answer.
You may be using multiple
these technologies
within your organization
because some teams value
one and other team's
value the other.
So I'm going to hand
it back to Debo.
We'll talk to you
about cloud storage.
And then I'll come back to talk
to you about managed serverless
Python.
DEBO ADERIBIGBE: Thank
you, very, much, Stephen.
Appreciate that.
So storage-- we've talked
a little bit about compute.
And storage is the very
obvious analog for resources
that you want to
make sure you keep
track of when it comes to
your business and your value.
Now, we talked a little bit
before about all the costs
involved with running your
compute processes and workloads
on-prem.
And you have to think, very
similarly, when you're thinking
about your storage workloads.
I won't go through all
the different elements
that we discussed before.
But I, of course, like
to call your attention,
very specifically, to the
idea that you have to think
about unavailability as a cost.
When you think about
not being able to serve,
either internally or externally,
the different types of data
that you have to
process for people--
that has a cost
to your business.
And you want to make that
you're aware of that, as well.
And you have to think about
repairability and other
elements like that
on-premises, as well.
Moving forward-- you also
have to think about the value
questions that you drive
when you're making decisions
with regards to storage on GCP.
For example, can you handle
multiple or single disc
failures?
How do you optimize for
different types of storage use
cases?
How do you instantly access
the different types of storage
that may hold the data
that's very important to you?
And let's say, that you
want to go more granular.
Let's say, I want to focus on
data servers, and structures,
and buckets, or
rows, and databases,
or in NoSQL
databases, and so on.
How can I take
advantage of all that
from a storage perspective?
So that brings us, of course,
to Google Cloud Storage.
In a nutshell, it's
very simple and elegant.
Just focus on creating
your storage buckets,
put the data that
you need into them.
And, of course, make sure that
you control your access, as
necessary, from a
public, internal,
or private perspective.
And then once you're
done, remove that data
and/or remove the bucket.
Now, I want to take
a minute to make sure
that you guys understand the
different classes of storage we
offer.
Because that's one of the great
values that we can provide.
And one of the great ways you
can extract more value when
thinking about your storage.
When you think about
multi-regional storage--
that's the most
frequently accessed data
that you're going
to have in your set.
More or less, it's going to
need to be access globally.
And you want to have
low end user latency.
And so, it's fantastic for
those global data sets.
Then, of course, you might
move into more durable and more
localized storage with regional.
Let's say, you need to do
some analytics processing
or you need to look
at some video encoding
for a specific business
or internal purposes--
that's more of your regional
data set or use case.
Then we move into more of
the less frequently accessed
storage or data use cases
with nearline and coldline.
Nearline is for data
you typically want
to access once a month or less.
So we're thinking about
redundancy or backup use cases.
And then, of course, coldline
is more of an archival use case.
So you want to
make sure you think
about your data storage and
some of those different types
of classes.
Now, I've told you-- just
as I did with compute--
that I have different
ways for you
to take advantage of
the different things
we provide in Google
Cloud Storage.
So once again,
I'll divide them up
into different
types of behaviors
and different types
of tools you can use.
On the behavior
side, you definitely
want to make sure that you
choose the right storage class.
You want to make sure that if
you need to have high frequency
data-- like, websites
or things like that,
streaming media that you
need other people to access--
you want to focus more on
the multi-regional section
of the use cases.
But if you've got
archival stuff,
focus on putting it in
coldline as soon as you can.
You want to make sure that
you properly tune your access.
The last thing you
want, as a customer,
is to think about
someone who you
don't want accessing your data
going into your storage buckets
and gaining access.
So definitely make
sure you do that.
Because that, of course,
increases the frequency
with which you need
to serve that data,
and might move it
across classes, as well.
Then the last thing
I'd tell you to do
is turn on Object
Lifecycle Management.
Object Lifecycle Management
is particularly useful
because you can move your
data across the storage
classes I just introduced
to you, by creating policies
that will do it automatically.
So in some cases--
if you're realizing that some of
your documents have a lifecycle
and they're frequently
accesses first.
But the less and less
relevant they get,
the less and less
they get access--
you can set specific policies to
move those things automatically
from, say, multi-regional
or regional
to coldline or nearline.
On the tool side
of the house, you
want to focus on using a single
API for all of those storage
classes--
that's particularly useful.
Because you don't have to
change any of your code
to access the storage
buckets that you're creating,
depending on what
class they live in.
Then we also have two things to
help you move your data around.
We have a Cloud
Transfer Appliance
and we have a Cloud
Transfer Service.
The appliance is particularly
useful in helping
you move your data
from on-prem into GCS.
The Cloud Transfer
Service is for moving it
from one cloud to another.
So both of those are
particularly helpful.
I encourage you to take full
advantage of both of those.
And finally, there's
a storage growth plan
to help you take care
of the volatility that
comes from dealing
with storage costs.
I'll give you a few
more comments on that,
more specifically.
The idea behind the
storage growth plan
is to help you think about how
I'm going to deal with the fact
that storage costs may
increase or decrease
fairly unpredictably.
So what we allow you
to do is if you're
able to commit to $10,000
of spend over 12 months,
then you can grow your
store data as you need to.
That volatility
will just happen,
and you don't have to worry
about overage during that time.
At the end of that
commit period,
you can either do one
of several options.
The first saying, hey,
at my peak usage--
I'm going to focus
on how much that
costs, and deal with the
overages now and renew.
Or I'm going to keep
my plan the same.
Settle up on all the overtures
I incurred over the past year
because I was able to think
about, and monitor, and predict
over that period of time.
And do this according to
growth storage plan terms.
particularly useful when
you have a lot of storage
and a lot of media
to take care of,
but you have no idea at first,
what it's going to cost.
So we've talked about the
value of Google Cloud Storage,
let's talk, again,
about the total costs.
One of the things
I'd imagine you'd
really want to
take advantage of--
especially if you're
just starting out
with Google Cloud Storage--
is to take advantage of
the always free tier.
That is, we give
you a very fixed
amount of regional storage,
a whole bunch of operations
that you can use in terms
of moving your data around
as necessary, and
network egress--
that's always free.
Just so you can get an
idea of how you want
to move those workloads around.
The other thing
to think about is
that costs decrease by access.
So you can look at the
prices per gigabyte month
and see that multi-regional
storage might be 3/10
of a cent per gigabyte month.
But as you move down the
storage class spectrum,
you'll find that coldline
storage is 4/100 of a cent.
So if you optimize
your workloads
for that kind of storage costs,
you can save a lot of money.
Then, of course,
there's the third thing
you need to think
about, which is
the fact that you can pay as
you go or use a storage growth
plan.
We're giving you
two options based
on how much you might know.
And how predictable
your workloads are.
Now, you guys might be
saying, Debo, this is great.
This is super awesome we
got Google Cloud Storage.
But I have to store things
at way more granular levels
than that.
What are my choices?
I don't want to overwhelm you
guys, but we have quite a few.
In fact, when you want to think
about all the different choices
you have--
there is very, very
ranging possibilities
from thinking about
relational databases or NoSQL
and in-memory databases,
block and file storage,
and, of course, the
general purpose storage
we were just talking about,
with Google Cloud Storage.
The main thing I want
you to think about here
is that it's also a spectrum--
very similar to what Stephen
presented to you with compute.
In some cases, the main value
of using some of these services
that we manage, some
of the boilerplate
work that you have
to do for you,
in exchange for an increased
cost, in some senses.
Or a simple cost and a simple
management structure in others.
And BigQuery is
included in there
as one of our great best
in class analysis tools--
that Stephen's going to talk
to you about just a moment.
In any case, take advantage
of all the different tools
and behaviors you can use
with Google Cloud Storage
in order to get the most from
your dollar, in that sense.
Now, I'm going to hand
it over to Stephen,
to talk a little bit more
about the serverless platform
and the analysis you
can do with BigQuery.
STEPHEN ELLIOTT: Thanks, Debo.
So the serverless
data platform--
there's many products that can
be tied into a serverless data
platform, but these
three give you
a sense of what we're
trying to do here.
And the echo should be loud and
clear from the managed compute
section that we
just talked about.
So BigQuery helps you
just write queries.
Don't worry about
provisioning the database,
the storage, the compute.
Just analyze your data.
Cloud Pub/Sub lets you
just send messages--
send the data where
it needs to go.
And then something
like Cloud Dataflow
is a serverless
processing pipeline.
So just process the data.
Don't worry about a provision
that Hadoop cluster--
for example.
So BigQuery is a
product I really love.
This is not just
me being biased.
My wife is a user experience
researcher on BigQuery.
So this is not just me
transitively loving BigQuery.
But it's a really cool product.
And what I love
about this diagram
is it shares the scale of it.
So it's based on Dremel--
Google technology that we use
to power our internal analysis.
And it's completely separated
the federated storage
of the data that it's analyzing
and the analysis of that data.
And what's especially cool here
is distributed memory shuffle
tier.
So basically, what
that is it's a way
for compute to be
completely stateless
and analyze a lot of federated
data, shuffling the memory.
So that if any of the nodes
go down, there's no problem.
The analysis doesn't fail.
If any of the
storage goes down--
it's no problem.
It's highly durable.
It's replicated.
So we have exabytes scale
storage on the left.
And we've got petabytes
within minutes scale analysis
on the right.
And if you just think
about that for a moment--
I used to work at
another company
before I came to cloud--
and it would be Monday night.
There was a Wednesday
metrics meeting that
was very famous in the company.
And I would hit contention
with every other product
manager trying to do analysis
on our data warehouse.
Because we didn't have
a million core cluster
that could scale 1,000
compute cores for my analysis.
I was always running against
other people on node-based data
warehouse systems.
So I really love this product.
And what you can
use that with is you
can use it as an
intermediate stop
for where your data's going.
So you might be using Cloud
Pub/Sub in your service data
platform to send messages,
maybe from your internet
of things endpoints.
Stand up a Dataflow
pipeline so you
can process all that
data going into BigQuery.
And then, maybe, couple that
with Cloud Machine Learning
so that you can
train on the data,
develop models that are reliable
and give you the right insights
from the data.
And then run those very
same models in Cloud ML,
to do prediction on
the streaming data.
So again, what we really
want to focus on here
is drive value from
only the pieces
that you want to work on.
So just write the queries,
just send the data,
just create the
pipelines, just develop
the models for machine
learning and then, only
pay for what you use.
So in the case a
BigQuery, what you use
is there is a charge
for streaming ingestion.
No charge for batch loading.
And then there's a charge
for the storage of the data
and for the analysis
of that data.
And actually, the analysis
comes in two flavors.
On-demand, which is just as
fast as what we see inside
of Google, is something
that just charges you
for any on-demand storage
based on data scanned.
But if you have
large BigQuery needs,
you can also opt for
a flat rate model
where you ask us to reserve
BigQuery slots for you.
And those are dedicated
slots that can
be saved just for your jobs.
And also, give you cost
predictability over time.
So that's something to consider.
In the case of Cloud Pub/Sub,
just pay for the data
that you sent in Cloud Pub/Sub.
Dataflow is the data process
plus the workers working
on that data.
And then, Cloud Machine
Learning is just
paying for the resources
required to train your model
and to apply it to data
to create predictions.
So end-to-end, what's
really beautiful
about a serverless
data platform--
you just focus on
the through line.
Where does the data come from?
Where do you want it to go?
And what transformations
do you want
to apply to it on
its way to, say,
your data analyst,
or your scientist,
or your business manager in
the visualization dashboard?
So we have plenty
of cases internally,
where we actually do
very similar things.
Comes into BigQuery
as a product manager.
I do, actually, analysis of
my own products in BigQuery.
And then power a Data
Studio dashboard with it
so I can see what's going
on with my products.
And it's all very, very
easy because I don't need
to worry about the resources.
So we've done a lot of
talking about total value--
how to think about total value
of moving to a more cloud
native way of doing things.
And the costs that come
with deriving that value.
So I want to spend a
little bit of time--
and there's deeper
sessions later and next--
but I want to spend a
little bit of time talking
about cost management tools.
So one thing we've
learned, just talking
to many different customers
of different sizes
is that regardless of
the size of the customer,
there's some common needs
for cost management.
And these are captured here.
There's the need to see--
to visualize what your
costs are in a way that's
meaningful to you.
And then to hold the
right people accountable.
So if it's me or Debo that's
overspending on the BigQueries
analyzing our products-- that's
something that we can analyze.
And we can see where the
costs are going, if we need
to do anything differently.
Same thing for compute and
any of the other products.
And then, of course-- if you
can hold people accountable,
you might also want
to be able to just
have control for peace
of mind and confidence
that you can run your
workloads in the cloud
with predictable costs.
And with the right
level of control.
And then, finally, you expect
to get some kind of insights
or intelligent
recommendations about how
to optimize your workloads.
And again, this is true
regardless of what size
of customer you are.
And there's something
that you should do
before you get to this phase.
There's a whole talk on this
that a colleague, James Byers,
will give on this.
But the way we like to
think about cost management
is we want to make sure that
you can manage your costs
the way you organize your work.
And this is, to a large extent,
is an offline discussion
with your teammates, with
your colleagues about--
how do we organize our work?
How do we organize the value
we're delivering as a company?
Do we organize it
by cost center?
Do we organize it by apps?
Front end versus back end?
And again, there's
no right answer.
And sometimes, a hybrid model
of organizing work and value
is important.
But once you have
a sense of how you
like to track the
value of delivering,
then we offer tools to help
you organize your cloud
environment that way.
So there's the organization.
It could just be your
domain name-- mycompany.com.
Folders that might represent
teams, applications,
or cost centers--
those are ways to
organize the projects.
And if you're familiar
with Google Cloud Project,
it's, kind of, the fundamental
unit of an environment.
Where all resources
within a project--
you can see the costs for
all resources in a project
and the usage for all
resources in a project.
And you can also control
access and policies
via this hierarchy.
And then, finally,
there are labels.
So there may be things you
want to be able to track
across your organization.
For example, security
workloads, R&D
workloads, other
overhead workloads
that might not belong to any
single branch in the hierarchy.
And so labels are something
else to consider using.
And the reason you
want to do this
is to be able to answer some
of these evergreen questions.
So talk about visibility,
accountability, control,
and intelligence.
The questions behind
those are fundamental,
and they tend not
to vary that much.
So what are the value and
costs of my applications?
What direction are
those trending?
Do I understand the
drivers of those trends?
And then, finally, what
might I do to optimize?
So optimization
might not simply be
about reducing cost,
but just making sure
that there's, again,
sublinear scaling.
That growth and costs-- if
there's much higher growth
in revenue, is absolutely fine.
But growth in costs
that might be greater
than growth in
revenue is something
to keep an eye out for.
And at any level of the
organization-- whether it's
the CIO, the business
owner, the engineering
manager, the
developer-- these tend
to be the same questions we
always get support calls about,
and we get into discussions
with customers about.
It just different zoom-ins on
the fractal of cost management.
And we provide tools to help
provide any level of visibility
that you might need.
So here's just a
summary of the tools.
And there's, again,
another in-depth session
on cost management that'll
go into these more deeply.
But we provide
out-of-the-box cost reports--
that you can slice and
dice your costs any way
you want within the
Google Cloud console.
If you want a more detailed
view of cost-- for example--
you really want to
get into the labeling
and you really want to
see things at an hour
to two-hour granularity--
there's detail billing
export, which sends all of
your cost data into BigQuery.
Because that's the
best place we think
we can send it for analysis.
And then for control, there's
budgets, alerts, and quota.
So one thing to keep in mind
there is budgets and alerts
are a lagging indicator.
What you spend is a little
bit of a lagging indicator
for cost control.
Quota, on the other hand, is
quotas set on usage by user,
by certain sets of permissions.
And that's proactive.
That gets in front
of the spending.
But depending on the
application, whether it's
production, testing--
you can imagine that
some usage of quota
is more appropriate than others.
And some usage of
budgets and alerts
are more appropriate
than others.
And the, finally, there
are recommendations.
So different products
have their recommendations
about how to optimize.
One that Debo
talked about was VM
right-sizing recommendations.
And there are other
recommendations
like that that we
can provide insight
into how you use your committed
use discounts-- for example.
And those just
help you figure out
if there are opportunities
to optimize your spending.
Or just reconfigure
the way you're
doing things to get the
most out of Google Cloud.
So to recap, I'll
bring you back to how
Debo introduced the session.
And we talked about
comparing value to cost.
And in particular,
just trying to seed the
thought that the usual
way of looking at this
is a little bit inadequate.
And then the
insidious thing about
this is this the way everyone--
I always think about things--
is just, how does
the cost change?
It's always harder to think
about how the value changes,
or how the culture of your
team changes, or how the way
you build things and
maintain the changes.
But if we can move from this
model of thinking about costs
and value to a model that
really thinks about what you get
from moving to very flexible
compute platform, a highly
diversified, and tailorable
storage platform,
managed compute services,
a serverless data platform,
and many other products that we
offer, and APIs that we offer--
then what, I think, is
the most exciting part
of this discussion is how
the value trend changes.
And just, the gap that it
opens between what you're
able to deliver to your own
customers and what costs you're
able to reduce on the backend.
So to tie it up, this is why
we call ourselves Google Cloud
Platform.
And we think the
more and more we
can be the platform that
you're building value on,
the more you can
focus on building
what's next for your business.
And that's why Debo and
I are at Google Cloud,
it's a really exciting.
People ask us, why are we
building product managers?
And it's because
this is actually,
a really exciting
part about our job.
And we really look forward
to working with you
as you do that.
So before we break, I mentioned
some other deep dive sessions.
A colleague of ours,
Manish Dalwadi,
is giving an intermediate
talk on how to save money
with Compute Engine.
And how to get value
out of Compute Engine.
I highly recommend that talk.
We have another
colleague, Matt Leonard.
He's doing a panel with
several industry leaders--
one from Etsy, a specialist
leader from Deloitte,
and a couple others--
on cost control and
financial governance.
And that'll be a
good one for you
to get a sense of the
different methods of having
good financial governance
and cost control,
depending on your
organizational needs.
And then on
Wednesday, I'm giving
a talk with that Deloitte
specialist leader
on actually using the
monitoring and cost control
tools that we offer as
the cost management team.
So we look forward
to seeing you there.
And then, finally, another
session that we'd like
to recommend is one run by
our colleague, Phill Coletti--
that's Phill with two L's.
And that's establishing
financial governance controls
on GCP.
And he's giving that with
[? Oralee Fontany-- ?]
who's a product
manager on quota.
And then, we'll be at the cost
management showcase all week.
There's an ask
the experts booth,
where you can schedule time
with one of the Google Cloud
staffers who are here.
And then, finally, if there's
one URL you want to write down
down-- its
cloud.google.com/costmanagement.
And we'll be posting all
the talks on cost management
there and other resources there.
So that's a great hub for
cost management resources.
[MUSIC PLAYING]